simplifica la raíz cúbica de 125 x a la
sexta y cúbica ahora tomar la raíz
cúbica de algo es lo mismo que elevar
ese algo a la potencia un tercio así es
que esto es igual a 125 por equis a la
sexta porque cúbica elevado a la
potencia un tercio ahora sí tenemos el
producto de varios términos que se
elevan a una potencia eso es lo mismo
que elevar cada uno de los términos a la
potencia y posteriormente hacia el
producto así es que esto es igual a 125
elevada a la potencia un tercio por x x
a la sexta elevado a la potencia un
tercio por que al cubo elevado a la
potencia un tercio que ahora veamos cómo
podemos simplificar cada uno de estos
términos 125 vamos a ver cómo lo podemos
factorizar en factores primos para ver
si hay algunos que se repitan tres veces
uno o dos que se puedan repetir tres
veces entre 125 es igual a 5
25 y 25 es igual a 5 por 5
así es que 125 es igual a 5 por 5 por 5
o 5 al cubo 5 al cubo elevado a la un
tercio esto nos va a dar exactamente
igual a 5 se simplifica entonces como 5
por y ahora x a la sexta elevada a la un
tercio esto ya lo hemos visto en otros
vídeos si tenemos algo elevado a un
exponente que a la vez se eleva a otro
exponente se multiplican los exponentes
aquí tenemos x a la sexta elevado a la
un tercio esto es igual a equis a las
seis por un tercio x a las seis tercios
es igual a equis cuadrada
así es que esto de aquí se simplifica
como x cuadrada x cuadrada y finalmente
aplicamos aquí el mismo principio y al
cubo elevado a la un tercio es ya la
tres por un tercio y elevado a la
potencia tres tercios oye a la 1 por lo
que esto está x ya hemos terminado y si
no quieres escribir estos signos de
multiplicación esto lo puedes escribir
como 5
x cuadrada 5x cuadrada que hemos
simplificado